if you want to build something great you
have to bring on a team you have to
realize that you can't do everything
yourself because there's only so many
hours in the day you have to get people
on board to help you build your vision
and help you become the best
entrepreneur that you can be otherwise
you can continually run up against the
time clock running out of time trying to
do everything yourself I'm never able to
reach the growth that you deserve you're
going to plateau because you're a
one-man show now it's hard bringing on
people is hard and if you look at any
entrepreneur any successful entrepreneur
you look at who the first employee was
almost all of them that first employee
is still not with the business
especially the early days of a business
you churn through employees and most of
it is your fault you didn't do the right
selection and what happens is and I see
it all the time with entrepreneurs who
come to me you figure I'm growing I need
to hire somebody I'm this is too much I
have so many opportunities and I can't
do it all myself I need to bring
somebody on board so you hire somebody
you spend the time the training the
searching it takes a ton of effort get
somebody up to speed and three month in
they quit or you fire them and then you
have to do all over again you got to
find somebody you got an interview you
got to train them that all takes time
away from you doing things in your
business and as a result a lot of
entrepreneurs get so frustrated with
that that they just throw in a towel and
they say forget this i'm going to keep
things simple I'm going to go just do
everything myself I know it'll get done
right and I don't have to worry and
waste my time trying to find people and
train them and worry about them and
that's one way to do but it's so
limiting the key thing and bringing on
the right people for your team is
understanding what your business is all
about having a rallying cry that they
can believe in as well I made a video
about marketing being about values and
the same thing applies to your team if
you are very clear and what
your business stands for and who you're
trying to help and in what you believe
in as a company these are the things
that we believe in that are core to us
that we will not accept things going
wrong on then if you can attract people
who believe the same things they're
going to stay with your business they're
not going to leave on you if you need a
programmer for your company you don't
just need somebody who has programming
skills there's tons of those people you
don't just need somebody who you can get
along with you need somebody who
believes the same thing that you believe
in and my business is all about helping
entrepreneurs I love helping
entrepreneurs I help entrepreneurs even
I'm not getting paid to help
entrepreneurs I make these videos
because I love helping entrepreneurs
even though there's no payday at the end
of a lot of the stuff I do I do it
because I love it and everybody on my
team loves helping entrepreneurs my
programmer ADIZ he loves helping
entrepreneurs he's a program he's got
great skills he's built all the code
behind my website but he also loves
helping entrepreneurs and that's why
he's stuck with me for years you want to
bring on the people who would do their
job even if they weren't getting paid
for now I'm not suggesting you don't pay
your staff but you want the people who
love with so much ideally you are doing
your business because you love it right
if you're not quit go find something
else you have to love your business and
you would do it even if you weren't
getting paid you take on part-time jobs
just to make ends meet so you can keep
building what you're building the people
you bring on have to have that same
feeling don't settle on bringing
somebody on just because they have the
skills you're looking for but they don't
have the belief in what you're doing it
all starts with you getting clear on
what you're all about what is your
company stand for what do you trying to
accomplish and making that explicitly
clear to everybody who you're dealing
with everybody who you try to bring on
they have to know what you stand for and
you have to get the same excitement and
feeling from them about that mission
most entrepreneurs don't have a mission
they don't have a vision they don't have
anything that they staying for
if you don't have something that you
stand for that you believe in
passionately then it's no wonder people
are leaving you because you weren't
clear in the first place over who you
wanted to hire and everybody makes this
mistake so you know if you've gone
through that don't feel bad this is your
opportunity now to change things around
clearly define what you stand for what
you believe in make sure it resonates
with you here in your heart to your core
like this is what you do and then
everybody that you bring on board has to
feel the same way about that belief they
have to have the skills that you need
and they have to have the values that
you have once you get that you've picked
a winning employee who will stay with
you for the long term and will pour
their heart into your business not just
do what you ask them to do not just do
it because you're looking over their
shoulder you're giving them tight
deadlines they do it because they love
to do it they do it because they want to
do it if those are the kind of people
you need to go after and it starts with
you getting clear on what you stand for
believe for those are you watching you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below it makes you want to do more
for you and I want to hear you have to
think every morning i turn on my
computer I eat my breakfast and I look
at the comments that come in so please
leave a comment to say if you liked it
or not and if you have a question for
your own business I'd love to create a
video apart for you leave it in the
comments section below thank you guys
I'll see you soon